♪ ♪
>> Brian: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
I AM NOT TUCKER, I AM
BRIAN KILMEADE AND ACCORDING TO
THE SCHEDULE I AM IN
PHOTOGRAPHER AT LEAST AN HOUR.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT IT'S
BEEN NEARLY A MONTH SINCE
JOE BIDEN PROMISED TO EVACUATE
EVERY AMERICAN FROM AFGHANISTAN.
ANY AMERICAN WHO WANTS TO COME
OUT, WE WILL GET YOU HOME.
HE SAID THAT.
IT'S A TALKING POINT THAT MANY
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS
CONTINUE TO REPEAT.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S ALLIES LIKE
SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER SAYING IT
TOO.
I WILL PUT THIS IN QUOTES
BECAUSE HE SAID IT, JOB BIDEN
RESCUED EVERY AMERICAN FROM
AFGHANISTAN, ISN'T THAT
INTERESTING.
AN EXTRA ORDINARY SUCCESS THEY
CONTINUE TO INSIST BUT IS IT
TRUE?
NO, IT'S NOT TRUE, AT LEAST
ACCORDING TO BIDEN'S OWN
STATE DEPARTMENT.
JUST TODAY ANTHONY FLANK AND
MUTTERED HIS WAY THROUGH A PRESS
CONFERENCE SAYING THAT THE
TALIBAN IS NOT ALLOWING --
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORTS IN KABUL.
>> AS OF NOW THE TALIBAN ARE NOT
COMMITTING THE CHARTER FLIGHTS
TO DEPART.
THEY CLAIMED THAT SOME OF THE
PASSENGERS DO NOT HAVE THE
REQUIRED DOCUMENTATION.
WHILE THERE ARE LIMITS TO WHAT
WE CAN DO WITHOUT PERSONNEL ON
THE GROUND, WITHOUT AN AIRPORT
OF NORMAL SECURITY PROCEDURES IN
PLACE, WE ARE WORKING TO DO
EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR POWER TO
SUPPORT THOSE FLIGHTS AND TO GET
THEM OFF THE GROUND.
>> Brian: AT ANOTHER TIME, WHY
WE DON'T HAVE ANYONE ON THE
GROUND AND ANY CONTROL OF
ANYONE'S AIRPORT BUT THAT IS FOR
ANOTHER SHOW, WHAT ANTONY
BLINKEN DIDN'T SAY IS THOSE
FLIGHTS INCLUDE AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THOUGH IT IS NOT CLEAR HOW MANY
PEERED OVER THE WEEKEND
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF SAID
THAT THERE WERE APPROXIMATELY
100 AMERICAN CITIZENS LEFT IN
AFGHANISTAN.
A WEEK AGO ANTONY BLINKEN SAID
IT WAS ANYWHERE FROM 100 TO 200.
THEY LIKELY DON'T INCLUDE
GREEN CARD HOLDERS CONSIDERING
THE ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T HAVE
A CLEAR NUMBER OF HOW MANY OF
THEM ARE ACTUALLY IN
AFGHANISTAN.
WHAT BLINKEN DIDN'T MENTION IS
THE TALIBAN ARE NOT THE ONLY
ONES BLOCKING FLIGHTS FROM
AFGHANISTAN.
FOX NEWS SHOWING THE
STATE DEPARTMENT IS BLOCKING
FLIGHTS AS WELL.
THE EMAILS ARE FROM A RETIRED
MARINE WHO IS EVACUATING HIS OWN
EVACUATION FLIGHTS FROM
AFGHANISTAN, PLURAL.
THEY ARE REFUSING TO GIVE
CHARTER FLIGHT APPROVAL TO LAND
IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT ALSO TOLD
HIM THE PRIVATE FLIGHTS WOULD
NOT BE ALLOWED TO LAND AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE BASES EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE TRANSPORTING
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND THOSE ARE
AMERICAN BASES.
"YOU NEED TO FIND ANOTHER
DESTINATION COUNTRY AND IT CAN'T
BE THE U.S., EITHER."
ISN'T THAT NICE?
NONE OF THIS IS STOPPING AFGHAN
REFUGEES FROM ARRIVING IN THE
U.S. HOWEVER.
ACCORDING TO GENERAL GLENN
VAUGHN HEARD OF U.S. NORTHERN
COMMAND, LESS THAN HALF THE
AFGHAN REFUGEES COMING TO THE
U.S. ARE SPECIAL VISA APPLICANTS
WHO WE KIND OF WANT HERE.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF AFGHANS
WE KNOW LITTLE TO NOTHING ABOUT
THAT ARE COMING HERE.
ALLOWED TO LAND ON U.S. BASES IN
OUR COUNTRY.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT,
ONE MALE AFGHAN REFUGEE WAS
RECENTLY DETAINED AT AN AIR BASE
IN GERMANY AFTER EXPLOSIVE
MATERIAL WAS FOUND IN HIS
CARRY-ON LUGGAGE BEFORE HE
BORDERED THIS FLIGHT TO ROME'S
TIME
, U.S. OFFICIALS BELIEVE THE
MATERIALS RELATED TO HIS WORK IN
THAT TERRORISM.
IT IS HIS JOB TO BE A TERRORIST?
JUST A THOUGHT, BUT HE WAS STILL
PLACED ON A RESTRICTIVE LIST.
ALL OF THIS COULD BE A CRISIS
FOR THE STATE DEPARTMENT AND
THEY WOULD BE FOCUSED
ON FIXING IT, RIGHT?
BUT THEY ARE APPARENTLY BUSY
WITH MORE PRESSING MATTERS.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE NUMBER OF WOMEN
IN THE TALIBAN'S NEW GOVERNMENT.
YESTERDAY A STATEMENT TO
"THE HILL," A SPOKESPERSON
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT THE LACK
OF FEMALE LEADERSHIP IN
AFGHANISTAN'S NEW INTERIM
GOVERNMENT.
COULD IT BE THE TALIBAN DOESN'T
REALLY LIKE WOMEN TOO MUCH?
DOESN'T GIVE THEM JOBS?
BUT I DIGRESS.
"WE HAVE MADE CLEAR OUR
EXPECTATION THAT AFGHAN PEOPLE
DESERVE AN INCLUSIVE
GOVERNMENT."
TALK ABOUT A STRONGLY WORDED
STATEMENT THAT WILL GET
EVERYBODY'S ATTENTION.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
ALREADY FAMILIAR WITH AT LEAST
SOME OF THE NEW GOVERNMENT
'SENIOR LEADERS.
WHY?
BECAUSE WE ALREADY GOT THEM ON
THE BATTLEFIELD AND POLICE THEM.
REMEMBER THIS QUESTION THE NEW
SENIOR OFFICIALS, FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA TRADED FOR A
TRAITOR.
A FORMER U.S. ARMY SERGEANT
NAMED BOWE BERGDAHL BACK IN
2014.
AT THAT TIME SUSAN RICE, SHE IS
STILL PLAYING IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, SAID THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING WAS BERGDAHL'S
WELL-BEING AND NOT THE FACT THAT
FOUR TERRORISTS THEY HAD JUST
RELEASED BACK INTO TALIBAN
LEADERSHIP.
>> TO SERVE THE UNITED STATES
WITH HONOR AND DISTINCTION AND
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN WHAT TRANSPIRED IN THE
LAST YEARS BUT WHAT IS MOST
IMPORTANT NOW IS HIS HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING, THAT HE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECOVER IN PEACE
AND SECURITY.
>> Brian: PRESIDENT OBAMA ALSO
INSISTED THERE WAS NOTHING TO
WORRY ABOUT.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> WE WILL BE KEEPING EYES ON
HIM.
IS THERE THE POSSIBILITY OF SOME
OF THEM TRYING TO RETURN TO
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE DETRIMENTAL
TO US?
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S BEEN TRUE OF ALL THE
PRISONERS THAT WERE RELEASED
FROM GUANTANAMO.
THERE IS A CERTAIN RECIDIVISM
RATE THAT TAKES PLACE.
I WOULDN'T BE DOING IT IF I
THOUGHT IT WAS CONTRARY TO
AMERICAN NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> Brian: WELL, IT IS, AND YOU
DID IT ANYWAY.
IT TURNS OUT IT WAS CONTRARY TO
AMERICAN NATIONAL SECURITY.
THE FORMER GUANTANAMO DETAINEES
HOLDING PROMINENT POSITIONS IN
AFGHANISTAN.
ACTING ADMINISTRATION FOR
CULTURE, ACTING A MINISTER FOR
BORDERS AND TRIBAL AFFAIRS,
ACTING DEFENSE MINISTER, THE
ACTING DIRECTOR OF INTELLIGENCE.
OF COURSE ALL OF THIS DEPENDS ON
SENATE CONFIRMATION